mito is sorting fish when other people
start talking about gone her 12 year old
nephew
gone is trying to cast the monstrous
master of the swamp a feat done 20 years
ago by mido's cousin and gan's father
ching it is a seemingly impossible
condition set by mido for she is
reluctant to allow ghan to take the
hunter exam
gon catches the fish and brings it to
the harbor to the amazement of the
townspeople and to the dismay of mido
the night before gon sets out mito tries
to convince gon not to pursue the exam
and become like his father
gon replies by saying he wants to know
why his father prefers to be a hunter so
much that he left his own son in other
people's care the next morning mito and
her grandmother bid gone goodbye after
he shouts that he will be the best
hunter gone is mocked by the ship
passengers who are also going to the
hunter exam site he observes the
applicants on board then he notices and
helps katso a crew member being bullied
by his mates gan then tells the captain
that a storm is coming
when the captain asks how he knows he
says that the seabirds flying above them
are warning each other of a huge storm
gone confirms it by using his sense of
smell the captain is suddenly reminded
of someone while the storm rages nearly
every exam applicant on the ship is
seasick except for gan kurapika and
lyorio the captain summons them and asks
for their reasons for taking the hunter
exam
gong quickly answers that he wants to
know why his father chose to be a hunter
the oreo and kurupika refuse to reveal
theirs the captain promptly tells them
that he is hired to trim down the number
of hunter exam participants before they
reach the exam site thus he can pass or
fail them depending on their response
kurapika reveals that he wants to be a
blacklist hunter to catch the phantom
troop who annihilated his clan the kurta
leorio wonders why kuropika has to take
the exam merely for revenge to which
kuropika replies that a licensed hunter
has unprecedented access to information
in places as well as the freedom to
actions that are otherwise forbidden
lyorio then states that he wants money
and the comfort and luxury it brings
like huge fortune and free use of public
amenities kuropika comments upon his
statement and leorio is ticked by
karapika not properly addressing him as
lyoreo-san several times already he
insults kuropika's clan as disrespectful
this sparks animosity between the two
and they go out to the deck to duel
meanwhile the crew members try to
stabilize the ship when katso is tossed
and is about to fall from the ship to
which leorio and kuropica witness in
horror
suddenly gone jumps out of the ship to
catch katso the other two promptly catch
gon's legs the captain is impressed with
them and he promises to bring them to
the port nearest to the exam site upon
reaching dahl harbor the captain tells
gone that going to the cedar tree at the
top of the hill behind the city will
lead them to the exam site gone relays
the information to karapika and lee
wario and they consult the map they
learn that the cedar tree is the
opposite direction of zabin city the
hunter exam site the oreo says that
there is a bus that directly goes to the
city
gone chooses to go towards the direction
of the tree lior bids goodbye as well
and walks towards the bus stop when he
overhears two senior applicants talking
about the bus ride is merely a trap for
new applicants the oreo joins the other
two and they reach a small deserted town
the oreo comments that there is nobody
around there but gone plainly states
that there are plenty of them a group of
masked people appear and block the way
with the stage where an old woman sits
she tells them that they have to undergo
the quiz in order to reach the cedar
tree she posts a riddle requiring them
to choose between two possible answers
and giving the answer within five
seconds
the three are taken aback by the
question for it is something that has no
correct answer unfortunately refusing to
partake in the quiz will disqualify them
from taking the exam a scheming
participant who overheard the
conversation between the captain and
gone has followed the three and goes
ahead to answer the mass people let him
by as he continues up the road the old
woman then poses a similar question to
the three angering leorio even more when
the time is up and no one is given an
answer
l'oreal angrily grabs a wooden stick to
hit the woman but is stopped by
kurumpika huropika tells leorio to calm
down for he will waste the correct
answer which is silence
a door to a tunnel opens and they are
instructed to meet the navigators living
in a house by the cedar tree upon
reaching the cedar tree they find the
navigators a couple being attacked by a
shape-shifting creature the kuriko while
leorio tends to the wounded man ghan and
karapika go after the kirika who kidnaps
the woman they are able to keep up with
the kiriko and gone hits it with his
fishing rod the curriculum drops the
woman and is saved by karapika but he
notices a tattoo on her arm and becomes
wary of her real identity lyorio comes
stating that he has given the wounded
man painkillers kurapika then attacks
him the fake leorio turns out to be
another kuriko in disguise and asks how
karapika knew kurapika states that even
if he was lorio he would have still hit
him for leaving a wounded person alone
the kiriko leaves and kuropika asks the
woman who she really is
meanwhile gone loses sight of the kariko
momentarily than it appears and he
follows it he loses sight of it again
then the kuriko jumps from a tree and
corners gone
gone is about to be hit when he flatly
says that the kuriko is not the one he
is pursuing
the carrico laughs hysterically and
calls out its partner the three
applicants reunite and the couple
reveals themselves to be the offspring
of the two kurikos they pass the three
due to their unique characteristics and
fly them to the exam site gone lyorio
and kuropika arrive at zabin city and
gone is fascinated by the bustling
selling and trading businesses there
they stop where a high-rise building
stands the three thinking it's the exam
site the navigator leads them to a small
restaurant beside it instead the
navigator orders something from the chef
who tells them to go to the back room
the order turns out to be the password
to the back room which is actually an
elevator that goes 100 floors
underground to the tunnel where
applicants wait
when they reach the tunnel they are
given identification numbers by beans
later they are befriended by tompa also
known as the ricky crusher he tells them
about the other applicants the most
notable is hizoka who merely killed an
examiner from last year's examination an
applicant bumps into hisoka without
apologizing and hizoka does something
that makes the applicant's arms
disappear
tampa then offers the three juice with
laxatives gan and lyorio quickly detect
that there is something wrong with the
juice saying that they might be expired
already another rookie applicant kiluah
approaches tampa and asks for another
can of juice he drinks it then tells
tampa that poison does not affect him
sadat the first examiner introduces
himself and tells the participants to
follow him through the tunnel as part of
the first exam phase the applicants have
run continuously for two hours a
distance of over 30 kilometers from
where they came from little rio starts
to get exhausted and he becomes
irritated when he sees an applicant
using his skateboard he sees it as a
mockery of the hunter exam but gone
defends the applicant saying that the
examiner just told them to follow him
without forbidding them to use whatever
means the applicant takes an interest in
gone and asks for god's age upon
learning that they are of the same age
he jumps from and catches the skateboard
with a maneuver starts running alongside
gone and introduces himself as kiluah
lidorio completely exhausted and covered
in sweat was on the verge of
surrendering and the rarity of rookies
passing the exam was all the more
affecting his enthusiasm the urge to
give up was approaching him until he
looked at gon who had decided to wait
till leorio wills to move forward
kilowatt is waiting for gone and tells
him to forget lyorio and just continue
but gone does not even move an inch to
kill allah's incredulity lurio gains the
motivation to catch up with the rest of
the applicants and starts running even
ahead of gan kilowatt sat out starts
increasing his pace when they reach 80
kilometers marked by a long wide
staircase the oreo now catches up with
kurapika who asks him if he is all right
quarapikal then asks leorio if he really
is after money because he doesn't see
leorio as such a shallow person
eliciting no answer kuropika shares to
leorio about the scarlet eyes of the
kurta clan as the reason for his clan's
demise
claim is possessing one of the seven
most beautiful colors in the world and
prized by people as rare wealthy people
as well as thieves like the phantom
troop want to get their hands on the
remaining pairs
kurapika plans to become a blacklist
hunter and be hired by wealthy families
to get access to the black market be
able to collect his clan's eyes and also
avenge them from the phantom troop
kurapika prods leorio about his reason
to be a hunter but he says that he
really is after the money lyorio snaps
back that his friend would not have died
if he had money then becomes embarrassed
by the revelation and turns away he
wants to be a doctor to treat poor
children for free but realizes that he
has to gain much more money to be able
to study
god and kilual also share their reasons
for taking the hunter exam kilua joined
for fun thinking that the exam is
challenging enough gone wants to be a
hunter like his father they agree to
have a race to the exit and the one to
win will pay for dinner
they arrive at the exit ahead of setouts
gon proposes that since he and killa won
they will treat each other to dinner
other applicants come and saddatz
introduce them to the location as the
milcy wetlands also known as the
swindler swamp he had just warned them
about the creature's creative means to
fool their victims when a man shows up
and drives with him an unconscious ape
with a face like sadazi's
he claims to be the examiner and accuses
of being a masquerading man-faced ape
the applicants become confused
especially leorio and hanzo and ninja
hisoka then attacks the two examiners by
throwing his blade sharp cards
the man with the ape is killed and is
eaten by scavenger birds
however saddaz catches the cards with
his bare hands proving himself to be the
real examiner and warns suzuka not to
attack him again lest he wants to be
disqualified he then tells the
applicants to follow him into the swamp
as the applicants run through the milsi
wetlands kilauea urges gone for them to
run ahead don agrees so they can follow
the examiner closely kilwa is more
concerned with distancing themselves
from hizoka for he senses his bloodlust
saying that he can smell it in the air
don then yells at kurapika and lioreo
that they should move up karapika and
lyorio witness many of the applicants
ambushed by several of the creatures
ghan and kiluah are captured by a large
frog in waiting who stays underground
and swallows anyone who steps on a piece
of ground that sits upon its open mouth
the frog then spits them out after kilua
spills inside the frog of the spiked
drinks tampa gave them kurapika and
leorio have lost sight of the front
runners they run into some applicants
surrounding hizoka telling him to
discontinue taking the exam for he is
too dangerous to become one hisoka
promptly finishes nearly all of them
with the circular sweep his card he
hurls killer cards onto the leader and
turns his attention to kuropika and
lyorio
gone notices that the two are still
nowhere near and leaves kilauea to
search for them
kurapika and lyorio choose to escape by
running in opposite directions
leorio later turns back to faces okafor
he cannot stand to run away after
witnessing such cruelty the oreo attacks
him but hizoka disappears in a whiff of
smoke hizouka is about to reach lyorio
when he is hit by gan's fishing rod as
his zoka walks towards gone lyorio tries
to attack him but is knocked unconscious
with an uppercut gon defends himself
while maintaining distance he cannot
attack his open head on so he uses a
trick to distract him unfortunately it
is hizoka who surprises him by reaching
him from the back hisoka holds him up by
the neck and enjoys gone's pain face he
lets go when god nearly passes out izoka
tells him not to fear for he will not
kill his friend and cites that both gon
and lyorio are worthy of continuing the
examination and offers to bring the
unconscious lyorio to the next
examination site after receiving a call
from somebody hizoka leaves carrying
lyorio on his shoulder and kuropika
approaches ghan
ghan and kuropika follow the orioles
sent to reach the next site don admits
to kurapika that it is his first time to
feel such fear but it has made him also
excited
meanwhile there are only 148 applicants
left ghan and kuropika reach the gate to
the next exam site and look for leorio
gone feels chills then sees izoka
pointing to lyorio sitting under a tree
the oreo is dazed and he cannot remember
the encounter with hizoka and how he got
hit in the face
ghan and kurapika opt not to tell them
what really happened
saddaa's bids would buy and the gate
opens to reveal a mansion with a
sprawling garden that is set up for
cooking menshi and buhari introduce
themselves as gourmet hunters and
examiners menchie states the second
phase involves cooking making the
applicants laugh and disparage both the
examiner's profession and the test
that's given after they all fail to pass
the test saddatz contacts the committee
about the situation
an airship hovers above the site as an
elderly man jumps from it landing on two
feet creating a crater then she
acknowledges him as chairman otero the
chairman proposes that menchie thinks of
another task and she has to show them
how to do it menchie requests the
chairman to bring them all to split
mountain where spider eagle eggs are
located the retest involves getting the
so-called dream eggs dangling on webs at
the ravine
menshi even demonstrates how to procure
the eggs by jumping onto the ravine and
dangling on the webs getting the eggs
without falling and timing the jumps so
she would be carried up by an updraft
the applicants who are not phased by the
task jumped to get the eggs some of the
applicants fall to their deaths failing
to realize that they should have waited
for the updraft the other applicants
rely on gon senses who signals when to
release their grips from the webs they
cook the eggs and find them delicious
bond shares the egg to taro who also
enjoys it only 42 applicants remain the
examinees and examiners board the
airship and chairman otero is formerly
introduced to the examinees beans the
chairman's secretary announces that the
airship will arrive at the site of the
third phase the next morning at 8 a.m
ghan and kilauea eventually settle in to
talk about their families gone wonders
about kilauea's parents and their
occupation to which kiluan nonchalantly
replies that they are probably alive and
they are assassins
gone is surprised and asks if both of
them are assassins
killalow shares that he comes from a
family of assassins and he's pressured
to perform as the future heir of the
family's business he had to attack his
mother and brother in order to leave
their home and find his own future he
even says dreamly that he will capture
his own family for a bounty when he
becomes a hunter chairman nitero sees
them and plays a trick by making them
feel someone else is watching them from
the other side of the corridor and then
appearing from the opposite direction
the chairman then challenges them to a
game that involves getting a ball from
him telling them that they will
automatically become hunters if they
succeed
kiluah even uses an assassination attack
rhythm echo to confuse him of after
images killua also hits the old man's
leg but it is he who feels the pain
gone also tries to catch the ball and
even teams up with killua the on and
kiluah are not able to get the ball from
the chairman kilowatt is secretly pissed
off and decides to quit
gone is adamant and vows to make the old
man use his right arm kilauea then bumps
into two of the examines along the
corridor and they confront him for not
apologizing
killua kills them in an instant and
mumbles that he might have killed the
chairman in order to get the ball had he
not left sooner meanwhile gone is able
to make the chairman use his other arm
to natarro's amusement
the airship lands on trick tower a
prison wherein long-term criminals are
kept
beans says that the aim of the third
phase of the 287 hunter exam is to
safely arrive at the bottom of trick
tower
one of the examines tries to climb down
but is eaten by six-legged flying beasts
gone finds out that the way it is to
flip one of the many large stone tiles
at all pick a tile and enter the tower
all of them end up in the same room they
see five watches in the room with two
buttons on each of them the prison
warden lippo says they need a fifth
person to advance further into the tower
that is because the route they have
chosen is majority rules where they have
to vote to do certain things in the
tower when given two choices the choice
that gets the most votes wins he is also
seen telling the prisoners to go to
their positions because the test is
about to begin
two hours later the final person joins
their group and he turns out to be tampa
a door appears
they have to vote whether to open it or
not
everybody votes to open it except tampa
the team advances forward and find
themselves in a large room the platform
in the middle on the other side there
are five prisoners gone and the rest
must be at least three of them in a
challenge to advance in the tower lippo
explains that there can be no draws and
that the prisoners get a year off their
sentence for every hour they delay the
examinees the first prisoner is bendot
who has been sentenced for 199 years for
robbery and murder tompa volunteers to
go first tampa immediately gives up and
then informs the team that he doesn't
want to become a hunter but he only
wants to screw people over the next
prisoner is senecan who has been
sentenced for 149 years for serial
bombings gone volunteers to face him the
end
the links for the next parts will be in
description and pinned in the comments
section
be sure to like and subscribe for more
awesome recaps